why do you get your hubby for his
birthday when your cardi b
and your man is offset a lap dance and a
lamborghini
that's what the migos rapper turned
29 on monday but on sunday cardi shared
two videos on her insta story
one featuring their two-year-old
daughter culture
as for the second post it was a whole
lot less family friendly
yeah like we said not so family friendly
that's the [ __ ] wrapper twerking on her
man upside down
and in a handstand the caption it's my
honey's birthday
oh yes honey later that day cardi posted
this sexy clip to instagram with a
special message for her love
quote i wish you more positivity wisdom
health and for
god to continue to keep you with a good
heart i love you
let's turn it up tonight and turn up
they did
[Music]
cardi threw the birthday boy a massive
bash and documented the whole thing
on instagram including the moment she
gifted him with
a new ride a lamborghini to be exact
which retails for about six hundred
thousand dollars
oh man svj
the perfect b day right well not so fast
all those unmasked party-goers had
people up in arms on social media
you know since we're in the middle of a
global pandemic and all perona paris
corona virus but this isn't the first
time the couple has faced backlash for
hosting a well-attended mid
covid soiree
[Music]
[Applause]
in november the musicians had several
guests over to their home to celebrate
thanksgiving
and shared several clips from the
get-together on instagram which
included a dance party
[Applause]
[Music]
and a whole lot of food
she later tweeted quote 12 kids and 25
adults over the holidays
it was lit yeah some fans didn't like
that
not one bit oh snappity snap snap i'm
nervous
and after cardi realized she had ruffled
some feathers she apologized
and explained that she had everyone that
came to dinner tested
adding quote i wasn't trying to offend
no one
[Music]